i am back in new york at christopher and
gay street wearing my gay hoodie and my
croc heels
yeah are those are crack heels wait yes
oh my god those are so ugly oh what was
queer space like on tick tock then have
you seen a change i was watching all of
these straight couples create these
challenges and so my endeavor was let me
try to do the gay version of all of
these and i think tick tock though has
always offered safe space for a lot of
queer creators and so that's why i think
a lot of people in the community are
drawn to the app in the first place
there's so much talk about the book of
queer i wish you were alive to see how
good you look dead because it's pretty
freaking hot man what did you know about
this before you went in
you know i knew we were going to be
doing kind of like
campy
gay historical reenactments
of things but i didn't really know
you know like how far we were going with
the uh campy fun part i am absolutely
living for these helmets tell me this
isn't giving everything it's giving it's
giving everything it's very easy to do
queer history for a queer audience it is
a more difficult to do queer history for
a mass audience so what were the things
that you guys felt that you needed to
nail in order to sort of bring this to
the people as opposed to the people you
know would watch anyway these queer
stories are in all of the history that
we've already learned about in a lot of
ways
we just have not been enlightened on the
queerness of it so i think being able to
communicate this as this is a story you
know this is a story you may have heard
before
now here's just the extra things that
that may have been left out
[Music]